this is a day when Bobby Kennedy took up
his job at the Department of Justice in
1962 one of the first things he did was
to redecorate his grand office with his
children's drawings he was a very
strange thing to do for most of human
history it's been unthinkable that an
important person would pin a picture by
a six-year-old to the walls of their
throne room art was meant to show
command of technical skills and
sensitive fidelity to the real
appearance of things but now children's
drawings are everywhere on our fridges
and the walls of our office cubicles
what is it about children and their bold
vivid and utterly wonky drawings that we
now see special Meriton it's not in fact
strange that it's this period of human
history that's been the first to get
really interested in children's art
societies get sensitive to things that
they're missing we live in a world that
demands enormous self-discipline and
charity we're surrounded by precision
technology and massive stifling
bureaucracies to survive at any degree
of success in these conditions we have
to be exceptionally controlled and
cautious creatures we have to give up so
much of what we knew in childhood just
together so what we find in children's
drawings are bits of our previous
personalities in exile tender playful
imaginative bits that we've had a
surrender to survive what's great about
children's art is how inaccurate it
tends to be a traditional assumption of
drawing is that if you're going to be
good at it you have to look very
carefully at what things actually look
like but small children don't give a
damn they don't try to look objectively
at a tree or hands or legs
the child is gleefully unconcerned as to
the true facts of the world into the
self conscious careful adult that you
feel very liberating indeed children's
art provides an opportunity to remind
ourselves about true means we need
discipline and rationality no doubt but
we also need play naive
and creativity where we don't need to
give it down children's art shouldn't be
just thought endearing it's a map of how
we should some time to remember to be
you